in an exclusive interview the family of
a British teenager killed in a car crash
in the UK explain why they are now ready
to sue the woman who caused it in the
United States nineteen yo Harry Dunne
was struck and killed in August by a car
driven by an cyclist she's a wife of an
American official she left Britain in
the middle of the investigation claiming
diplomatic immunity
MTS tyub spoke with Dunn's parents last
night very late last night after they
arrived in this country because you you
did this interview at one o'clock in the
morning Wow so we did Bravo to you that
you're sitting struggle what is their
goal here it's pretty extraordinary and
as you say the family has just arrived
here in the u.s. to pursue this civil
case it should be at but really this
case is extraordinary and now an
extraordinary legal precedent that they
hope to use the Dutton family's lawyer
plans to rely on ancient English common
law dating back to 1774 which says even
though the offense may have been
committed in one country the accused can
face charge in another now as ever for
the Dunn's this isn't just about justice
it's about closure
we're solving limbo we're trying our
hardest to get this result for hurry and
get the truth out there almost four
months after their son Harry was killed
while riding his motorcycle
Tim Dunn and Charlotte Charles are set
to meet with their new legal team in
Washington it must be so exhausting yeah
it is exhausting it's 24/7 but as a
family we feel this is the right way we
we feel is it's the way we have to go
and so coolers had just left the Air
Force Post where her husband was
stationed when she hit done while
driving on the wrong side of the road
Saku says legal team previously told CBS
News she had no time to react before the
crash and that she cooperated with local
investigators she needs to still face
what she's done to us
and take some punishment for that the
family is yet to meet cyclists
face-to-face but they came close back in
October when they met President Trump at
the White House circus was waiting to
meet them in a room nearby hey was it
was some quite bizarre looking back on
it now thankfully as a family we
discussed many scenarios including the
most bizarre and ludicrous one that we
could come up with which was the fact
that and securest may well have been
there what were you feeling in that
moment to be honest we didn't really
feel a lot I think the show that said
it's all yeah because we talked about it
we all do look in our minds that if an
was there we were going to say no
because as a Charlotte has said it was
it would have been unfair on her and on
us and now months after the crash
Harry's family says they're facing a new
challenge the holidays without their son
he from what we know loved Christmas and
he's not gonna be there this year how
does that feel
yeah we're not doing Christmas this year
we used to have to chop the top off of
the tree to get it into our house
there's not been a year gone by where
both of the boys harry especially it's
like you know when are we getting the
tree you know you make sure it's bigger
and better this year mom it's gonna be
horrific this year and I think the
trouble is it's gonna be difficult from
now on every Christmas
because Harry loved it summer because it
was his favorite charming yeah now we
talked to the lawyers of representing
this American woman about this legal
step but did not receive any comments
that we also spoke to some legal experts
who tell us that they also have
questions about jurisdiction if and when
a lawsuit is filed here but really the
big question here is diplomatic immunity
will it extend to the coolest now that
she's back here in the US remember in
the beginning they told us all they
really wanted was an apology they said
just apologize and talk to us they have
not received the apology that they want
and they want to see her
in the UK facing the criminal justice
system in the UK but they say
emphatically they don't want her to go
to jail you just want her to wish the US
and the British government's could find
a way to give a solution holidays are
always the hardest yes thank you very
much